have you seen that thing from the
smithsonian yes before i even explain
yes
well let's let's break it down for the
honest time break it down where it's
like scheduling is whiteness
and like being on time and working hard
saving for the future
i saw that and i thought to myself those
aren't familiar like the smithsonian had
this chart whereas like a graphic
explaining that
like i said working hard is considered a
a trait of being white i'm like wow
white supremacists would completely
agree
but what i what i thought when i saw
this was have they never been to like an
african country
like people have jobs people have
schedules people work hard people say
for the future
they're racists they literally think
that like these countries in africa that
function that have employees and
businesses and that are predominantly
black
don't have schedules yeah don't save
money in a bank also
you have to imagine that whoever created
that that poster
i'm sure they had to meet a deadline at
some point
you know they they had to they had to be
able to compose
uh compose their sentences properly and
make their points
you know it's follow their their their
schedules their their their schedules
it's it's this um
i mean i had an argument uh with one of
my harlem roommates actually
and he actually was mad at me i was
talking about striving for a financial
success he was like he's like man that's
just
he reacted man that's just another way
of striving for trying to be white man
and i was like
there's a lot of nigerian and japanese
businessmen i think who disagree with
that notion
you know but how but how sinister is it
how insidious is it
that these people who claim to be
fighting on my behalf
say that anything that you could
possibly do to improve your life
means that you are not really who you
are
you know it's it's it's and people and
people can't see it because i mean
that's the power of i don't know
the leftist brand the democrat brand
whatever you want to say but you know i
mean i left the democratic party two
years ago because
i began to say you know what these
people are not they're not in my corner
they're telling me all these things that
are going to lead to a terrible life and
a life of
of dependency and and insecurity and yet
they still want me to vote for the
politicians that are pushing forward
these same things you know and
you know i i i shudder to think of how
much money i could have right now if i
just
just decided to say you know what
everyone's racist and and i'm a victim
and uh and don't pay pal exactly
give me a book deal or you know or you
know nike please give me money
mcdonald's please give me money this is
the funny thing about when they say like
grifter and all that stuff it's like
dude
do you like you realize the corporations
support the leftist narrative
if i wanted a big sponsorship from big
brands who paid big bucks and i was
really intending on grifting people
i'd just be a leftist yeah that's like
all of these major brands change all
their logos to rainbows and and you know
candy canes and all that stuff
and i'm i'm sitting here i'll be honest
it's not like this show is like
far right conservative or anything like
that but i just not
i just no certainly not apparently not
though then what am i doing here right
down the middle
i mean that's the funny thing too it's
like the centrist doesn't exist to any
of these people
no it's funny so like i i have a uh you
know some descriptions of me say
tim pool has been variously variously
described as left wing and right wing
it's like
maybe it's because i'm a centrist like
like we we
some i think there are some things
conservatives got right i think they're
the ones
standing up for free speech for the most
part right now you definitely got
conservatives who are pro-cancel culture
they'll say they aren't but they would
they they would want to cancel people if
they had the chance yeah for the time
being
there are more moderates and
conservatives who are saying hey don't
ban speech
the left the neo-liberal left for the
most part is anti-speech shout out to
jacobin i know a lot of people don't
aren't fans of them but for a leftist
socialist publication
they've defended free speech for some
really important people saying right
they'll come for us the moment they cut
you you let them go for them so i can
respect that i don't care where you are
in the spectrum if we believe in freedom
individuality
you know self-respect and all that stuff
or like a um responsibility i think it's
just easier way to put it
all of that's kind of going out the
window these days like the whole the
whole idea is that
i guess on the left you are
it's a really it's a really horrible way
to live you are responsible
let me put it this way you have to do
what the left wants you to do and if you
screw up it's your fault
you get no benefits for being an
individual you have no right to work
they create villains to keep you in line
but the moment you make a mistake
then you are an individual then they do
sacrifice you then they do come for you
you know what i mean yeah it's um i was
actually
attended what they called a salon um
this was in new york city
um it was hosted by by an actor friend
of mine
a brilliant guy excuse me and um he
showed this video
where this guy explicitly said people
tend to focus too much
on the individual we need to focus more
on the collective
and i was like well yeah
i was very silent during that entire
affair people were like what do you
think black guy i'm like
i mean this is one of those things where
you had to walk in they had these um
these bracelets at the door
that and you had to put one bracelet on
for each mark of privilege that you had
so you know if
if if your if your parents went to
college
wear a bracelet if you if you are able
to vote
wear this privilege bracelet you know if
if you have a mother and a father it's
just like
there's this this i mean it's a secular
religion man there's all these like
there's self castigation it's just it's
it it's it's so insane to me i took the
pretty much see it i took the privilege
test and i scored very very poorly
oh i'm sorry tim very poorly yeah so
it's like
it it asks you a lot of a lot of
questions are you religious
you know are you white are you male it's
like what's your gender what's your race
what's your religion
what was your family's income level and
all of these things have you ever been a
victim of this a victim of that and i'm
going through it and it was like it's
like you are very underprivileged or
whatever and i was like i never knew
that
i never knew that like i i guess i
understood growing up we weren't rich
but it never mattered also what what is
what is the right amount of privilege
you notice nobody nobody ever really
dictate or
or or quantifies what that is you're
over privileged or you're
underprivileged but no
what is the perfect amount of privilege
that we're that we are allowed to have
i don't know because i know you can't
quantify it that's the problem i know
people that were born in pretty much the
same situation
strong family and part of like they
looked like their surroundings so like
that familiarity bias i don't think it's
a racial thing i think it's like if
you're familiar with your surroundings
you know
someone looks like me and a weinstein
basically says this yeah yeah
and but they're like losers no offense
to you guys if you can hear me out there
and you know who you are
um but they never made much of
themselves but they had that they still
had that privilege
and then i know people that i had to i
was a huge nerd i mean look at me
i would like pushed around in school i
would talk like this in school and
people be like you're
get out of my you know weirdos it was
hard but i had i had some privilege but
you have to strive to make something
yourself regardless of
what kind of privilege so the privilege
is not gonna it's not gonna give you the
success you have to take that
no you know you know i read something
interesting uh i was talking to a friend
of mine this guy i know
and he said that he was shocked he was
not that he said
it's shocking that we don't teach
juneteenth in
schools and i said bro they taught me
juneteenth in school
i think the issue is your school didn't
teach you juneteenth
so i don't know where you went to school
in the city
yeah we we we talked about it i i'm not
going to pretend like the school
celebrated or anything
but i remember like opening up the book
and then reading about you know this
history
and i think the issue was like where he
grew up in his community
perhaps his community didn't like
there's certain stories and certain
things they didn't think were as
relevant so they ignore
them it's not like you're going to teach
literally every child every grade school
kid about every bit of history
and i thought it was interesting that he
said that because i was like first of
all it shows you that your
experience is you think your experience
is the world's experience
you think because they didn't teach you
that i wasn't taught or other schools
don't
that's just you man yeah and it's it's
really funny because uh i don't know
you're familiar with ryan long the
comedian
yeah i know who he is but he's got a new
bit and it's brilliant where
it's basically a therapist telling the
woman no matter what she does wrong
she should tell the world to change
instead of her so he's like
when she's like you know i can't seem to
find a good guy he's like have you
considered writing an article telling
men what they can do better
but it's a good point because when i
hear people say like why aren't schools
teaching this i'm like bro they do
not all of them and not yours so maybe
there's an argument
but then why don't we teach the holiday
more you know what i mean like you
choose what you think matters to you see
the problem
i'm not here to to disrespect anybody's
struggles or plights
and i also don't know what what history
is more
important based on privilege is the
holladamur ignored because it was white
people oh i'm sorry
the coalition of communities of color
said that slavs slavic people
are are people of color now so does that
mean that we are ignoring
a a genocide of people of color in in
the holodomor by not teaching this to
great
great school children or does it make
sense because juneteenth is literally an
american
you know a holiday in 47 states and it
should be more prominent in this country
well these are these are
just conversations like i work backwards
right so we were talking before we came
on air you know i'm
binging a lot of thomas soul right now
and he goes
in on what he calls intellectuals the
intelligentsia
and how they and and visions of the
world you know i think everyone should
read a conflict of visions
to sort of get a grasp on it's its
soul's attempt to
highlight the the roots of the
ideological uh
fissures of our time and he talks about
uh the intelligentsia in terms of
journalism and journalists and how they
tend to filter out
uh facts that are inconvenient to to
their own vision so you know why don't
we teach the holiday more well it's
inconvenient to the leftist vision of
the world you know and
juneteenth isn't so they're bringing it
up now and then and then um talking
about
who you know they're not they're not
teaching this in schools i mean i
remember
there was some tweet about uh um uh
people like to forget about emmett till
i'm like who is who has not been told
about emmett till
everyone knows who emmett till is i
don't know who is not teaching that um
teaching that but again it's like you
know who is he
are you serious yeah no see this is a
good point though like wow well so so
emmett till was this kid uh
who basically he was accused of
whistling at a white woman this was back
in the the 50s i want to say
and he got the crap beat out about beat
out of him you can find pictures online
of his corpse it's it's beaten beyond
recognition
you know they they beat him they threw
him and you know they threw him in a
body of water i mean it was it was awful
it was horrible
but every person i've met except for ian
apparently knows
that story and uh but this idea like
we're not teaching this is is wrong the
last thing i want to say just working
back a little bit
is that juneteenth june should be black
history month the one stereotype
the one stereotype out that i will
accept about black folks is that we do
not like the cold
they gave us the shortest coldest month
to celebrate
all to celebrate our history why is that
nice and that's just ridiculous to me
but but even better when you said june
june should be black history month i'm
like that is the month of june
exactly it makes sense it makes me i'm
launching a campaign right now no i'm
kidding can you guys briefly
forgive my ignorance explain juneteenth
and the voldemort
can you explain those really quick oh
god hold on moore basically uh stalin
uh lots of policies that led to uh
starvation of millions of ukrainians
um the new york times uh famously under
a journalist named walter durrante who
has an award named for him and
this guy later won a pulitzer prize
which the new york times has not
rescinded
he deliberately filtered out as i said
before the information about the hall of
demore
and meanwhile there was another british
journalist and i i i wish i remembered
his name but he was actually reporting
what was going on and he got smeared and
so impoverished long story short holly
moore was a genocide of
ukrainians the soviet union took all
their food away from them basically and
they all just started starving to death
it's brutal horrific juneteenth i've
heard a lot about it but i would love
for some clarification
oh i i don't remember what it is it's
like it's like the emancipation
it's the it's it's essential it's the
june 19th the celebration of
the the day i think i could be wrong the
day the uh
the union marched in texas and enforced
the end of slavery officially it was
like the last person who was still
enslaved got like
oh finally and there's a move to make it
a national holiday
so interestingly in more recent times
47 states already have it as a holiday
and i got to be honest i i think
we should absolutely as a nation
celebrate juneteenth i really i really
it's a significant event it's it's
independence day man and i've heard
the leftists talk about how it's like
they you know we finally said
this is the end of slavery and i'm like
dude absolutely like it was a horror
it's a horrible thing
and i'm all about you know more
celebrations for america and the things
we've done right
so the fourth of july i'm down you mean
i get another one a month before to
celebrate what i'm saying
do you know do you know do you know how
much barbecuing is going to happen
if we put black history month in june
all right man come on man let's
just just make make it happen comment
make it happen
so i'll tell you i'll tell you the issue
i take with a lot of the critical race
theory a lot of the leftist approach to
things
is like i'm you know i did an hour-long
documentary on ferguson
and pruitt i go and public housing and
the racial covenants of saint louis
systemic racism institutional racism and
and you know when i when i sit down with
conservatives and trump supporters
and actually have conversations as like
human beings sitting down together to
have discussions
we actually come to an understanding of
each other's views and politics and
understandings
and if there's something like ian wasn't
familiar with juneteenth i'm not content
to be the expert i probably got some of
it wrong but i'll just be like oh so
it's basically this
so when i talk to conservatives treating
them as
humans and good people who just you know
maybe don't understand
then all of a sudden they're like oh i
didn't know that that's interesting like
surprise surprise when you actually sit
down with someone have a conversation
with them like
they may still be like well i disagree
with these particular points so the
issue i take is
we just basically said on this show
juneteenth should be a national holiday
we should have tons of barbecuing and
the problem with a lot of the mainstream
left is that they need the conflict
like when you mentioned your roommate
who said you know you know you're just
trying to like act white or whatever
that was
it's like they've they've created the
villain that those of us who are
fighting for civil rights and have for a
long time in social justice
are trying to do away with this idea
that people are villains based on race
we want to be like no no people are
villains because they're bad people with
bad ideas and they want to hurt you
but there are good people of all
different races there are bad people
involved in different races
but i think the people who want power in
politics and sometimes it's republicans
i think republicans have a lot a lot of
faults but democrats absolutely love
using
race as a wedge to drive
a push for power and i'll give you a
really good example they complain the
republican party is too white
it's a bunch of white men they say and
then when the rnc
had several prominent blacksmiths they
insulted them
yeah and and called them all the awful
racial slurs and i'm like
so you asked them to do better the
republicans were like absolutely you're
right
and then you insulted the people who
spoke like dude
i can complain about mitch mcconnell and
lindsey graham and the weak
republicans the phrase republican
leadership is an oxymoron
i think everybody watches know i say
this all the time the democrats are
something else
you know i grew up in chicago and i feel
it's probably one of the reasons why i
have a bias very much so against
democrats i think it should be obvious
to anybody
that group in a democrat-run city i was
personally screwed over by democrats as
somebody who was
you know essentially a liberal living in
the city republicans didn't affect me
anyway i watch mitch mcconnell and what
does he do he goes slow down their
democrats and then he obstructs things
i was talking to a democrat friend and
she was just saying all he does is sit
on things and stop things from happening
and i'm like right and the democrats
actually do stuff they do stuff that's
either bad for us
or they do like or they don't do what we
want to do and they do bad things i'll
put it that way
like you get joe biden two thousand
dollar checks everyone says yes fine
they agree and then he doesn't do it he
goes and bombs syria instead
and again i know you know donald trump
missile strikes drone strikes all the
bad stuff too
there's a lot to uh unpack breaking down
all of that stuff but ultimately
i really do feel like the democrats are
worried if
we actually had the conversation where i
was like oh i don't really care about
race or gender and stuff i think people
are you know should be treated
respectfully
and and you know we should come together
and fight for common causes particularly
class issues
oh that's bad news for them well i'm i'm
convinced
that most of us in this country agree
on a lot of things there are some hot
button issues like like abortion for
instance that
are just really emotional and people
have very divergent views on that but i
think we agree
on more things than we are led to
believe and i say all the time get off
of social media
uh get off of don't stop watching the
news and just start talking to people
and you'll see just how you know when i
when i uh
left when i left new york city uh the
the
dystopian wasteland that it's now become
um and i
and i went to a city like atlanta and
you know i was so heartened by just
talking to people who are not in this
progressive bubble who they have
they're connected to life in a way that
people in new york city are just
are just not and they have concerns that
that you know that
that new yorkers just don't that aren't
that aren't really they aren't really
privy to
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time